tutti i grandi passaggi della storia
sono partiti da un'idea folle dirompente
tabù tutti i grandi progressi sociali
scientifici tecnologici sono partiti
dall'immaginare all'impossibile prima
ancora di capire esattamente come ci
saremmo arrivati dietro queste idee
innovative
ci sono sempre stati gli individui
capaci di portare dietro di loro di
riunire centinaia migliaia milioni di
voci e di forze chiamate in causa e
convinte che cambiare si può dietro
ognuna di queste grandi idee c'è sempre
stato un uomo né donna che ha iniziato a
nuotare controcorrente
l'importante è partire osare rischiare
provarci
gli imprenditori sociali sono questo per
noi sono uomini e donne che scoprono le
cause profonde di un problema sociale o
ambientale e trovano delle soluzioni
creative per risolverli in fondo lo
spirito imprenditoriale e questo
intraprendenza creatività leadership e
coraggio tipicamente gli imprenditori
sociali
iniziano a trovare ad avere dietro di sé
alcuni seguaci che iniziano a seguirli
forse all'inizio per migliorare le
proprie condizioni personali o quelli
della propria famiglia ma capendo che in
un secondo momento si potrebbe
migliorare le condizioni di molti e
magari poi di tutti diversi studi
dimostrano che quando il 16 per cento di
una popolazione
inizia a cambiare un comportamento
sociale da lì in poi in brevissimo tempo
tutti gli altri seguono con una crescita
esponenziale
questo succede per comportamenti sociali
umani ad esempio la diffusione dei
telefonini cellulari
inizialmente un gruppo ristretto di
persone
poi un gruppo di precursori ed infine in
brevissimo tempo ce l'avevamo tutti in
tasca ma non solo succede anche in
situazioni sociali
non umane di altre specie quando il 16
per cento di uno stormo per esempio
inizia cambiare direzione
ecco che seguono tutti gli uccelli
quando il 16 per cento di pesci cambia
direzione di nuoto ecco che seguono è
anche segue tutto il banco statistica
questo viene rappresentato in questo
modo un gruppo ristretto di innovatori
che insieme ai precursori fanno il 16
per cento e da lì nello stesso tempo in
cui questo cambiamento è successo
riusciamo ad ottenere un cambiamento
massivo fino a quando poi arrivano anche
i ritardatari ashoka l'organizzazione
globale che rappresenta in italia da 35
anni è alla ricerca di questi innovatori
sociali di questi imprenditori sociali
di questi pesciolini che iniziano a
nuotare controcorrente quello che
facciamo a sceglierli per la loro
creatività e lo spirito imprenditoriale
la loro fibra etica il loro impatto
sociale e la loro innovazione li
sosteniamo economicamente ma soprattutto
circondandoli da una rete di esperti di
consulenza e di alleati che possa
portare questi cambi di paradigma che
hanno trovato a diventare universale per
noi il modo migliore per risolvere tutti
i problemi sociali del mondo non è
quello di implementare dei programmi
dall'alto ma di andare a trovare chi ha
già scovato delle soluzioni per quanto
imperfetta o applicabili solo localmente
ma ad aiutare queste persone a portare
questa innovazione a diventare un cambio
di paradigma universale ashoka opera da
35 anni in 85 paesi al mondo
15 paesi europei ma arrivato in italia
solo l'anno scorso
in tanti mi chiedevano perché siete
arrivati così tardi non ho tutte le
risposte ma una possibile
interpretazione che il nostro paese
dalla fine della seconda guerra mondiale
fino alla crisi petrolifera degli anni
70 è riuscito veramente a compiere un
miracolo
attraverso il lavoro l'intraprendenza la
creatività di uomini e donne
e con l'allora con la loro innovazione
con la loro forza hanno portato un paese
distrutto dalla guerra e in larga parte
povero a diventare una delle potenze
economiche più grandi del mondo ma non
solo abbiamo creato uno stato welfare
tra i più solidi al mondo abbiamo
innovato nell'arte nella medicina
nell'architettura in quasi tutte le
discipline poi paradossalmente dagli
anni 70 in poi più diventavamo un popolo
istruito e colto meno ci siamo messi ad
innovare siamo diventati esperti di
analisi dei problemi con pochissima
attenzione alla critica e al cambiamento
quali sono i risultati questi sono dati
di quest'anno sul lo spirito
imprenditoriale in 200 paesi al mondo
siamo terzultimi dopo la bulgaria un
paese ex comunista e il suriname a chi
ha coperto dall 80 per cento da foresta
spirito imprenditoriale e capacità di
cambiamento vanno a braccetto per questo
per noi la scuola i genitori gli
educatori devono insegnarci a provare a
sbagliare imparare dai nostri sbagli a
capire se si è trattato di un errore
strategico metodologico o semplicemente
di sfortuna riprovare fino a quando
riusciamo ad ottenere un risultato e
questo vale per un'impresa sociale per
un'impresa economica o per qualsiasi
progetto di cambiamento che una persona
possa avere in un mondo fordista basato
sulla ripetizione poteva anche avere un
senso sistema educativo universale
standard adatto a tutti ma dalla società
contemporanea in continuo cambiamento
c'è bisogno di sperimentazione di
innovazione c'è bisogno non di
omogeneità ma di creatività non di
nozioni ma di opinione
io ho avuto la fortuna di studiare in
una scuola pubblica in italia fino a 17
anni in una classe come questa questa
una foto scattata tre giorni fa ma a
parte quel minuscolo computer credo che
evochi a tutti un ricordo della scuola
che abbiamo fatto
in questo paese poi a 17 anni ho avuto
la fortuna ancora maggiore di essere
selezionato con una borsa di studio per
finire i miei studi in canada ero
appassionato di filosofia e ho deciso di
continuare a studiarla anche la ma non
avevo mai letto un testo originale da
noi la filosofia era interpretata e
spiegata attraverso il libro di testo
poi a sua volta interpretata e spiegata
dal professore più la si ripeteva uguale
a più alto era il voto
arrivato in canada il professore e
distribuisce a tutti una copia del
simposio di platone e dice avete una
settimana per leggerlo poi settimana
prossima ne parliamo
e così leggo questo libro in realtà
molto più interessante scabroso di come
ce lo definiva il libro di testo è
tornato a scuola
andrew chiede alessandro tu che hai
studiato già filosofia dimmi un po cosa
ne pensi da convinto le interpretazioni
di platone della morale ed io
addio criticare platone non mi
permetterei mai
per fortuna però col tempo ho imparato
che tutto era criticabile perché tutto
si può cambiare
in realtà la buona notizia è che questo
non c'è mai stato nessun momento più
opportuno per nessuno di noi nella
storia dell'uomo per poter cambiare
tutte le cose e nel minor tempo
possibile e anche se forse pensiamo di
essere continuamente minacciati da
attacchi terroristici da guerra di
religione da catastrofi climatiche
in realtà non c'è mai stato un momento
in cui sono stati meglio come homo
sapiens questi ad esempio sono alcuni
dati sui morti per le guerre nella
storia dagli anni 40 ad oggi
come vedete il numero è in continuo calo
e guardate che la popolazione del mondo
nel frattempo è quasi raddoppiata la
speranza di vita aumentato sta
aumentando dovunque nel pianeta
la mortalità infantile sta diminuendo
dappertutto
abbiamo sconfitto la maggior parte delle
malattie che per secoli e secoli e
millenni
l'uomo ha dovuto combattere certo ci
sono tanti problemi sociali ancora da
risolvere i problemi ambientali sono
ancora più importanti e più difficili da
risolvere ma siamo connessi e
interconnessi e più che mai oggi la
globalizzazione è la tecnologia ci
permette di trovare una soluzione in un
angolo del pianeta e di portarla
ovviamente adattandola culturalmente in
un altro angolo del pianeta
abbiamo quindi la possibilità di
risolvere tutti i problemi sociali
se lo vogliamo questo è il compito di
ashoka selezionare l'innovazione
accompagnare gli imprenditori sociali in
quei pesciolini che nuotano
controcorrente per far sì che la loro
innovazione possa diventare un movimento
che acceleri il cambiamento sociale nel
tempo un altro compito importante è
quello di mettere insieme gli innovatori
sociali che operano nello stesso campo
sebbene in posti diversi e con metodi
diversi ad esempio tutti gli
imprenditori sociali che lavorano con i
bambini da zero a dieci anni ci dicono
che la cosa più importante in assoluto e
insegnare loro l'empatia cioè sapersi
mettere emotivamente nei panni degli
altri non la matematica non l'italiano
ma l'empatia chi lavora quegli
adolescenti ci dice che la cosa più
importante nel segnare loro è quella di
metterli nelle condizioni di vedersi
come attori del cambiamento nella loro
classe nel loro quartiere la loro scuola
nella loro città e il mondo intero si
possono sembrare dei concetti forse
eccessivamente astratti strambi però
provate a pensare come poteva essere 300
anni fa a dire tutti i bambini devono
imparare a leggere a scrivere non solo i
figli dei nobili oppure 150 anni fa dire
anche le donne devono poter votare non
solo devono potere proprio diventare
presidenti e ministri a loro volta o
anche solo trent'anni fa a dire due
uomini e due donne che si amano devono
potersi sposare
e invece guardate questo successo questi
sono alcuni dati sulla diffusione
dell'alfabetizzazione nel mondo
l'analfabetismo fino al 1600 era
condizione praticamente universale nel
1700 è passato ad essere la condizione
dei poveri
comunque la stragrande maggioranza della
popolazione
poi col diffondersi del protestantesimo
e quindi la necessità da parte anche
dell'uomo comune di leggere la bibbia e
inizia ad emergere un nuovo paradigma
che per noi è stato enunciato nel 1720
da william lee che dice tutti non solo i
file dei ricchi devono imparare a
leggere a scrivere questa diventa prima
una battaglia all'interno della chiesa
poi all'interno dello stato del regno
unito dove operava anni e da poco a poco
a l'inps nel 1820 il 20 per cento della
popolazione sa leggere scrive anche poi
diventa 40 50 70 fino arrivare al giorno
d'oggi
all 85 per cento della popolazione
globale in inghilterra un paese in cui
viveva si è arrivati al cento per cento
nel 1920 dall'annunciare nuovo paradigma
alla sua universalizzazione in
inghilterra sono passati duecento anni
circa otto generazioni e vorrei
presentarvi ora un altro caso questa
persona si chiama kate c'è pregio che in
scena nel 1890 nell'oscura e remota
colonia britannica chiamata nuova
zelanda dice una cosa che non era mai
stato detto prima
tutte le differenze di razza di
religione di classe ma anche di sesso
sono sbagliate e quindi devono essere
combattute ma kate non era soltanto una
brava oratrice era soprattutto una brava
organizzatrice riesce a coinvolgere
dietro di sé migliaia di donne che
appoggiano la sua battaglia per i
diritti politici politici delle donne ma
non solo riesce a tirare dietro di sé
anche degli uomini con cui nel 1893
riesce ad ottenere lo storico risultato
di far votare le donne della nuova
zelanda
da lì inizia un processo che nel corso
dei decenni vede sempre più paesi
approvare il suffragio universale
maschile femminile
come vedete quando si arriva negli anni
30 e 40 circa il 16 per cento
da lì in poi vediamo un impennata e
molto velocemente se arriva agli anni 70
80 in cui praticamente tutti i paesi del
mondo davano la possibilità quando ci
sono elezioni poi vere o finte è un
altro discorso
anche alle donne di votare al giorno
d'oggi tutti i paesi al mondo tranne
città del vaticano e brunei concedono
questo diritto
possiamo quindi vedere come un paradigma
possiamo pensare una bambina nata nel
1890 in un mondo in cui nessuna donna
può votare che muore a 90 anni
nel 1980 in un mondo in cui praticamente
tutte le donne possono votare il tempo
si è ristretto ancora di più nel corso
della vita di una persona vediamo
l'emergere di un paradigma e la sua
universalizzazione ma vediamo ai giorni
nostri
questi sono due ragazzi negli anni
settanta in minnesota
jeff beck mai come bonus che decidono di
volersi sposare fanno una cosa che non
era mai stata fatta prima vanno
all'anagrafe le chiedono di potersi
sposare civilmente
ovviamente la loro richiesta viene
derisa e poi bocciato ma già lì parte un
nuovo paradigma i diritti delle persone
omosessuali non sono solo diritti
individuali ma i diritti di coppia
da lì quindici anni dopo nel 1989 a
danimarca approva le prime unioni civili
nel 2001 la l'olanda prova il primo
matrimonio egualitario fino ad arrivare
negli ultimi 15 anni in cui praticamente
dappertutto nel mondo occidentale in
america latina qualche sorta di unione
tra persone dello stesso sesso è stata
approvata siamo nel mezzo di questa
impennata del 16 per cento e mentre
prima erano secoli poi decenni
ora si tratta di anni e abbiamo così una
persona come me che nasce nel 1982 in un
mondo e qui nessun omosessuale si poteva
sposare quando finisco le elementari
parte l'idea di unione civile in
danimarca
quando finisco le superiori in olanda
una coppia si può sposare a 29 anni
posso sposarmi
e argentina a 34 anni finalmente anche
in italia il mio matrimonio viene
riconosciuto
se vi chiedete dove sono adesso jack
michael stanno ancora insieme e
finalmente sono sposati
quindi il mio lavoro è proprio questo
riuscire in italia a scovare chi in quei
pesciolini che nuotano controcorrente
che possono portarci a un cambiamento
sociale a un cambio di paradigma ed
aiutarli ad accelerare questo cambio di
paradigma gli imprenditori sociali sono
merce rara cene circa uno ogni dieci
milioni di abitanti quindi in italia di
al compito di trovarne circa 6 all'anno
questi sono i primi sei che ho trovato
uomini e donne eccezionali che ci hanno
veramente fatto capire dei cambi di
paradigma che potrebbero diventare
universale
c'è chi ci insegna che la lotta alla
mafia non è soltanto una scelta etica ma
una possibilità di sviluppo economico e
psicologico di alcune tra le popolazioni
più povere d'europa
chi ci insegna che la maternità il
congedo di maternità e anche di
paternità è un'occasione per imparare a
un'occasione utile a noi ma anche alla
società intera e datore di lavoro o chi
ci insegna che la riabilitazione da
ictus infantile può essere un gioco non
necessariamente ospedalizzato da dove si
parte da qua ovviamente il mondo non si
può cambiare con questi sei o con le 34
persone che lavorano con me
occorre che tutti facciano la loro parte
tutti possono essere attori del
cambiamento
vuol dire che ognuno può essere attore
del cavatore del cambiamento
se siete ad esempio dei genitori batte
tv perché nelle vostre scuole
iniziano insegnarsi queste nuove
competenze ho provate a insegnarle voi
direttamente a casa
se siete degli studenti battetevi non
solo per riportare alla scuola come era
trent'anni fa qua ma per capire cosa c'è
di nuovo
e cosa potrebbe cambiare veramente la
vostra vita come cittadini non solo come
studenti se siete dei media
provate a parlare anche di storie
positive di cambiamento non solo di
tragedie se siete nelle aziende non
vedetevi soltanto come macchine di
produzione ma come co creatori del
cambiamento se percepite un problema
sociale
non aspettate che sia qualcun altro a
fare il primo passo ma fatelo voi
se credete che il cambiamento è
possibile non aspettate domani il
momento giusto e oggi grazie